whether you're making your octagon debut
or putting the final touches on a Hall
of Fame career every UFC fighter shares
the same goals put on a show and finish
the fight an EA sports UFC too we knew
that if we wanted you to truly feel the
impact of every strike landed our
endgame fighters would have to feel them
to reacting in the most realistic ways
possible enter the new knockout physics
system from simple setup strikes to
devastating haymakers new hit reactions
provide organic visual cues that let you
know just how much you've rocked your
opponent lam that knockout blow and you
experience the most true-to-life
physics-based knockouts ever seen in an
MMA game and every finish becomes a
unique visceral experience
we've improved the controls to allow
independent high or low blocks as well
as provide more precision with parrying
strikes and setting up that counter
we're also giving you 360 degree control
of your fighters head movement so you'll
have full range of motion when evading
attacks our new dynamic grappling system
makes turn-based action a thing of the
past as both fighters are now free to
advance defend or transition at any time
this not only allows for more dynamic
and fluid clinch and brown battles but
also the ability to create scrambles as
fighters contend for position and with
the grapple assisted now available to
act as a roadmap anyone can roll like a
pro thousands of new animations mean
grappling and submission attempts can
now be seamlessly chained together use
the counter takedowns and even slapped
on in the clinch to create incredible
finishes in the blink of an eye so
whether you're starching or submitting
your opponents bring in a competition to
its knees and the crowd to their feet
has never felt this satisfied or
there's a Finnish waiting in every fight
where you find it is up to you
you